let's imagine a modest sized skyscraper
about 100 meters and 30 stories tall a
high rise this size was almost certainly
built with concrete which contains
cement in this case about 6 000 tons of
cement making that cement probably
emitted about 4 600 metric tons of
carbon into the atmosphere that's about
the emissions from driving a car for 12
million miles now multiply that by all
the buildings in the world even that
wouldn't capture cement's carbon
footprint think about the sidewalks
you're walking on many of the streets
you drive on a lot of our energy
infrastructure dams power plants all
that cement production accounts for
eight percent of all Global carbon
emissions more than the aviation and the
shipping Industries combined today most
of those emissions are due to China's
rapid development in just two years
China produced more cement than the US
did in the entire 20th century other
developing countries will use a lot of
cement as they build tall cities in
infrastructure too
if we want to reach Net Zero in a few
decades we'll have to figure out how to
build a building like this without
emissions it'll be hard but there's a
way
you're looking at a typical cement plant
one like this is currently operating in
nearly every region of the world this
rotating tube a kiln and this Tower a
preheater are where all cement emissions
take place about 40 percent of cement's
emissions are a result of burning fuel
to heat the Kiln it reaches around 1450
degrees Celsius near the heat Source the
preheating tower is where Limestone
Clays and other additives are dropped
the 850 degree temperature here causes
Limestone to release its stored carbon
dioxide and those are the other 60
percent of emissions
the first question about decarbonizing
cement is whether we can just use less
concrete altogether we typically use up
to two to three times too much concrete
and design Architects and Structural
Engineers just use lots of it it doesn't
hit the bottom line and makes the thing
more reliable and they're less likely to
get sued and kill people and what have
you in a building concrete is valuable
for its compressive strength its ability
to hold up under a lot of weight so it's
hard to substitute its use in places
like foundations and columns but
elsewhere we should minimize it I was in
the new Parliament building in Scotland
and it was obviously designed with
greenhouse gases in mind concrete was
only used where needed steel was only
used where needed and they used
laminated wood for the roof for a lot of
Structural Materials things that weren't
load bearing carbon conscious design can
certainly chip away at cement's
emissions but replacing concrete
altogether won't be possible in the near
term so cutting down on excess concrete
can cut Emissions on our high rise by
roughly 26 percent according to one
analysis we'll have have to do more and
the next place to start is how cement is
made looking at the forty percent of
emissions that go into firing the Kiln
is one place to start typically cement
plants use coal or petroleum Coke or
natural gas to heat the Kiln to 1450
degrees Celsius you could Electrify that
but it's really hard to achieve that
high of a temperature with electric heat
though some startup companies like this
finish one are trying until we get there
cement plants have started to just burn
different things the high heat makes
cement plants a good place to incinerate
Industrial Waste trash or used tires the
Limestone basically scrubs out any
nasties that are produced in the flame
here and stops them being emitted into
the atmosphere switching fuels can cut
emissions by roughly seven percent we've
still got a ways to go so let's look at
the other way cement causes emissions
the chemical process
this is the carbon released from the
heated Limestone once it goes through
the Kiln it becomes a material called
clinker the key binding ingredient in
cement and cement binds together the
rocks and sand and water and concrete
cement is about 10 percent of concrete
but accounts for a majority of its
emissions so one strategy is to find a
substitute for the clinker startups have
been in a race to develop a new kind of
green cement that avoids clinker
altogether but so far nothing is as
abundant and commercially viable as the
Limestone based stuff an adjusting
concrete formulas takes a lot of time
and safety testing for good reason the
events in Turkey recently there was a
lot of substandard cement being used
there and there was a lot of substandard
building practices in North America
clinker accounts for about 90 percent of
cement due to safety standards but North
America is overly cautious compared to
the rest of the world the average
clinker to cement ratio globally was
about 72 percent in 2020 that's made
possible by clinker-like sub institutes
we could reduce the clinker ratio even
more experts emphasized one new cement
mixture that gets the clinker ratio
safely down to 50 by supplementing it
with more clay and unprocessed Limestone
that's what an existing technology that
meets existing building codes that'll
cut half the emissions from the cement
and concrete industry these reductions
will help in reducing emissions but
until we find a scalable zero emission
cement any clinker production at all
will inevitably have process emissions
which brings us to the last piece of
decarbonization the cement industry will
need to use carbon capture and storage
to get there there's no way around it
this would mean capturing the carbon
emitted from the Heat and chemical
processes here and storing it deep
underground in a geologic deposit
a cement company in Norway is piloting
one of the first cement plants in the
world to capture carbon and they'll
store it under the North Sea in their
oil and gas deposits some new companies
are also finding a way to inject stored
carbon back into cement and concrete
during production this takes advantage
of Rock's natural ability to reabsorb
carbon and potentially one day we may
even see our build environment become a
carbon sink which we don't usually think
about when we think about large concrete
cities and large buildings and our roads
and all of that so this is the scenario
in which we get this building to net
zero emissions and the goal right now is
to get there by 2050. that requires us
to start now and aggressively especially
in China the world's biggest producer
but experts told me there's some good
news there so in the U.S the average age
of a cement plant is about 34 35 years
in China it's 15 which means that many
of their plants are actually more energy
efficient than the plants that we have
here China uses less clinker in their
cement than the global average and they
have at least one carbon capture project
in the works but there's a long way to
go last year they pushed back their Peak
building deadline from 2025 to 2030.
changes to design and the concrete and
cement processes will be the easiest to
implement but carbon capture and storage
is at very early stages and all this
will be expensive it's estimated that
the cement used in this building will
cost somewhere between 70 to 115 percent
more the cost of cement or concrete is a
very small fraction of the overall cost
of a project so it's relatively easy and
cost effective for a government agency
to commit to paying a little more for
the material to absorb that green
premium the U.S inflation production Act
is helping create a market for carbon
capture and Storage by increasing tax
credits to 85 dollars per metric ton of
carbon stored for a long time heavy
Industries like cement seemed like
unsolvable climate problems but today we
know how to fix them and we can't afford
not to try
thanks for watching the video as a
follow-up to this one I'd recommend
checking out my co-worker Phil Edwards
great video on the world's tallest Mass
temper building in Milwaukee Wisconsin
he was able to film the building under
construction and he gives a great
explanation about how changing from
traditional materials like steel and
concrete to Wood changes the entire
building process wood probably can't
replace concrete in all the world's
buildings one expert I interviewed told
me we'd probably have to Triple the
amount of wood harvested in order to
scale it up and do that and that would
come with its own environmental problems
but our big concrete problem requires a
lot of different solutions and using
wood when possible is definitely one of
them and as you can see from Phil's
video it looks really cool too